how's it going ray my name is ill here
bad
welcome to silence : yo Silencio I got a
map now it doesn't work apparently
crisis there we go
where is it black cat yes
oh this bathroom cool always check out
the bathroom inside
that's something happen
spirals and prostitutes
[ __ ] this Amiens bro alright let's go to
the bathrooms hello oh I don't like this
okay we got one of these
we need to collect four of them my
pencil T let me just take a piss
done BOM jab blood I hate when it
happens every [ __ ] time I go out of
the door ah I can't go in there
[ __ ] me
alright I know there's an axe uh you'll
get an axe later on and they really
don't see you well these little [ __ ]
[ __ ] me alright alright alright no
problem
lovely lovely lovely why there today and
GED days Oh jolly good a first aid kit
splendid hooray alright what else do we
got over here a blood bag lovely a Blood
Pact that could be helpful
ah [ __ ] me of course it's like well you
gotta be up domestics playing with the
this little thing now this is my
emulating it's not that good you
probably see me I'll [ __ ] up anyway yeah
let's check in here you gotta check all
the rooms because if you don't
hey washing machines are you doing
washing machines sorry I went down
lovely lovely
hey girl doggystyle all right I'm out of
here
no dog it's all for you stop chasing me
bro I thought they didn't see me
alright let me just look at the map real
quick alright okay let's check all these
rooms look No what do I got hey a bad
kite birdcage I saw this Silent Hill
movie and they use the birds to alarm of
the darkness but I don't know if they
follow the movie so we'll see if this
bird has any importance
hello girls don't mind me we're back
here [ __ ] man
oh cool doggy style ladies Oh change
nation [ __ ] am i doing gotta learn my
invitation that it Oh another one
Oh shotgun shells I guess I need that
can we do something with this TV VCR the
it's old but usable alright probably
find the tape and go back here so soon
room 202
I'll remember that but that on my jolly
memory
how you doing lady alright what do we
need to go there yeah left run lady
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh sure Chet Chet Chet
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
the lamest oh no she's in here oh [ __ ] I
don't remember how to shoot all right
calm down I know how to shoot
I just don't not aim [ __ ] they take so
many it's my health that's my mother
[ __ ] hell doing pretty good I'm not
I'm not too shabby with that controller
it's thank you back thank you for
suggesting I do listen I don't listen I
don't know how to walk normally and the
aim being a man's is like the scariest
thinking about this game seriously all
right what about a steel plate it's
screwed to the wall more mysteries well
I'm all tied on my might jolly good
jolly good period lady hello hello I'm
done here I think all right sneaky pills
sneaky pills activate don't count that
don't go back works every time
stupid [ __ ] all right
all right what do we got over here it's
too dark to look at my penis
I mean map all right I don't know remove
three or five
Oh a libido back three or five sounds
splendid check it out ah this is really
bad
this is extremely bad Hey ladies are you
dead stop grabbing me disgusting [ __ ]
desperate I'll shoot you I'll shoot you
time for shotgun what'd I do
I'll try there don't raise your hand
girl where is it alright let me finish
you up fail hey what's your name hey
girl girl what's your name how you done
just getting out of give a [ __ ] hahaha
Dada da ba da let's our skippity school
skipping school skippity schemes give it
escapes get with it let's go on here
[ __ ] don't waste your shotgun ammo well
you know what you live in your waist
it's one my mom all the same what is
this
give it to me plate of cat alright I
think we all need one more and then we
all know all the lovelies oh it's not
that loud it's weird huh alright not
complaining
and we are done let me check a lot for
like a get in here can you tell a
meeting
oh sweet dude all right well [ __ ] it
let's go near hey lady
let me just go to the bathroom
[ __ ] oh hey all right
can't see me in the die oh yeah this is
where I put the subs I don't need to be
here right now let's check this out
Jack
at a window
Bock don't kill me
she can't see me shower mode activate
don't come closer
are you gonna be a problem go pits go
pads go what are you doing okay what the
[ __ ] is that sound tentacle porn lovely
stop doing that I'm serious I don't have
that much ammo all right
but she has a soap how do I get that
Penta Kapoor knee
what do you want let's give him food do
you want I'll give you a plate of cat
fine I give you blood yes that'll work
take it disgusting
don't mind me I'm not a rape victim
don't put anything up my [ __ ] rod all
right nail let alright do it oh [ __ ]
doing pretty decent I'm just investigate
a little more stop moaning not gonna
have sex with you
alright alright alright alright
we have not checked out room room 0-1
like Shaq thank let's over here if we
are lucky very high girl I go watch
shadow one hey boy where you going
shooting ever lighter this is the last
piece o shine [ __ ] ah plate of Quinn ya
think we got them all
cool cool now we can take the elevator
back given hey hey then cool all right
here it is [ __ ] that took me a while sky
on a sunny day
tangerines that are better lucky
four-leaf clover violets in the garden
danja leans along a path unavoidable
sleeping time liquid flowing from a
slash wrist
that's lovely things to hear so since
since I'm a genius
in general when it comes to a lot of
things um was this Queen I think right
where do you want to put it well here
uh-huh so that's nice we put one of them
what are you Hatter let's put you in the
opposite there you go bra keep doing
what you're doing a lot of love man a
lot of that all right I don't want to
remove anything all right and then we
got the turtle turtle is blue as a sky
so I will make you die that does not
make sense I'm sorry I said that
patro and the [ __ ] can finally there
was a gap let's up this wax it sounds
promising
God abattoir enemies okay
don't even worry about it stupid
[ __ ] so what am I now ooh the scary
parts all right all right hello
bye bye where did it come from stop
attacking me I go move you [ __ ] shut up
oh no no no no no no no I came so far no
no no no don't hurry hurry the corner if
you don't like it then you put the
[ __ ] bullets in it if you don't like
it then you put a lot of bullets in it
I need that hammer why I have a not
gotten it yet
what is she one I'm invisible I'm
invisible cat mo crazy [ __ ] is in my
way Oh
cool sorry quite enjoyed it not dead yet
are they they are gotta finish it off
like you're finish off a baby seal with
your dick hey how you done don't give a
[ __ ]
Oh a key lovely lovely lovely lovely
hello
stop following me you're desperate son
of a [ __ ] desperate
no one likes here not even Oprah and she
likes everyone hello
let me get that no now today lady I said
not today
what part of not today did you not get
all right what is that other thing it's
not a videotape
can you stops can you stab me some other
time because I'm kind of busy right now
kind of busy got things to do
appointment this is going jolly good
what look at miss skip alright
hello all right oh look at that dance
you don't see dances like that every day
more of you huh I'll just go in stealth
mode I don't have ammo for you some milk
that's nice a disinfection alcohol it's
lovely
oh it's there it's the seat belt hello
bye-bye
holy [ __ ] damn bein sis
hello nice meeting y'all
that is locked all right so we only got
this door oh thank God thank you mr.
Chang now what a bad pitch I love you I
love you too bra you're my bra you're my
darling you're my darling yeah My
Darling Clementine yes my darling oh my
darling oh my dog no idea what are we
gonna do with these things I'm just
gonna go and save pretty much
and in the meanwhile I shall sing I
don't wanna close my eyes I don't wanna
fall asleep cause I'm playing Silent
Hill and I just gotta go over to the
save scheme does not make them let me
say whenever I want to save cuz it is a
[ __ ] and I don't want to replay haha
I'm not done yet alright room 3 or 2
what's the same feel 0 2 you are an
idiot for not finding a pair today and
let's save this [ __ ] game
alright brother gotta end this episode
EA uh I can favorite appear I died
please tell me what the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to do because I really don't
know from this point anyways love you
but top it off yeah
huh
like a mix of hips and email and the
ugly